you look amazing i need to know every
single secret about this dress
how many sequins do you think are on
here oh gosh yes
so i'm wearing giorgio armani and i
feel like a badass i must say
it's been a minute since i got glammed
up and i really wanted to kind of just
have a little this caller is a little
bit um
nodding to aapi heritage month which i'm
very excited about obviously um and
it's really nice to feel i don't know
like shiny
again you look shiny and i i love that
it has a special meaning to it i think
that's incredible and i love that you're
honoring that
i also love your nails they're very
sparkly thank you yes they're very
sparkly and they have detail
underneath my nail girl
happy belated birthday by the way thank
you so much how did you celebrate
um my boyfriend and i went to
a lodge and spa in the middle of nowhere
in the forest
and we just relaxed and had spa
treatments and went hiking and it was
really nice and
i'm 24 now 24 not messing around
crushing it how does it you are crushing
it how does it feel
my birthday yeah i feel it i'm glad to
have made it another year around the sun
gotta say i i like that you went from
there a relaxing weekend to here
probably your first red carpet in over a
year
yeah i'm assuming yeah how does it feel
to be back in person
and to be at the movie awards and it
feels
great i mean i i i was here a couple
years ago and it
i i have to say it was i'm a little
nervous just because i haven't been
around
people at all but it feels really great
and i'm really happy that
kind of my first time back is with the
mtv movie awards because i feel like
it's family and i really enjoy the
company of everyone so
we talked to you recently about the
potential kitty spin-off
for to all the boys and i just want to
know if that spin-off does in fact
really happen is there room for lara
jean
and peter in the spin-off gosh i mean
i would absolutely support anything that
anna cathcart does because i think she's
amazing and
i think she did such a great job with
kitty and
i mean i love the taller boys world
more than i think people understand like
i myself am a huge fan so
i'm always open to visiting that
universe again because it was one that
was really
kind and beautiful do you think they're
still together lara jean and peter
in this spin-off universe gosh i don't
know
i kind of have this like feeling that
they're not gonna make it through
college but they're gonna come back it's
gonna be fine
everything's gonna be fine they're gonna
like when they're like 40.
okay so they have maybe a split and then
a reconciliation moment
yeah yeah i think it's like it's like
the drama yeah i get it and it's also
like you're young and you're in college
and then you realize what you're doing
after
finding yourself god knows i am i'm the
same i
understand you also have a project
coming out with mr cole sprouse yes
what can you tell us about that how is
it to work with him are you a riverdale
fan
well i haven't worked with him yet um we
haven't started production on that but
that will happen pretty
soon um and i'm really excited it's kind
of a rom-com adventure
um in space which is very
fun and i've never done anything like
that so and
you know cole and i have gotten along
very well he shot me for a magazine like
years ago and ever since we've gotten
along very well so i'm really excited
is that how this sort of came together
where did you guys talk beforehand
where you guys remained i mean i think
it came together very organically
um i loved the script when i first saw
it and
of course i mean i think space is just
really cool and he was a perfect fit for
it
so you know it came together organically
but i am very excited
you also have a new show is it boo biz
can i say it okay
[ __ ] become a [ __ ] yes what
what is that about it's your you're kind
of the boss of this show right
i yeah well i'm executive producing and
starring in it um with netflix which
obviously i love and is my family they
love you
and it's just a really fun comedy
raunchy comedy um with a little bit of
paranormal
activities sprinkled through so it'll be
fun
i'm excited last time i talked to you we
talked about the boyfriend you were
hoping he was going to propose
yes i see a ring but it's not on that
number i don't know it's
you know maybe not maybe next time i'll
see you maybe next time
so it's coming tell me about this ring
though is this uh
it's very ring shiny um
i am like afraid to lose because if i do
i'm doomed um and
listen i'm very aware that it's on my
finger so we're just gonna
keep it safe keep it right here it looks
like a lot of carrots
i think it is yeah okay well thank you
so much it's so good to see you as
always you look fantastic great to see
you
loving the ariana grande thank you tony
no we love her
yeah you can't help it